last week layla and i signed our wills
donating our entire estate to charity
more or less that obviously happens
after we die so it's not now but it was
a really interesting experience for me
to go through because it put a lot of
things into perspective
within life and so um i wanted to share
some of the thoughts around that because
i made an instagram post about it and
it's gotten the most like likes and
comments and interaction out of any post
i've made to date and so i figured uh it
was a point of interest
the reasoning behind kind of that
decision
is um is is multi-fold and so i'll share
that with you so the first is
we are of the belief that
i mean one we don't have kids and so we
would have we have no like direct
descendants we'd pass it to second even
if we did have kids or have kids in the
future
i don't think that giving people a lot
of money when they do not earn it is
good for them all the people that i know
who were given money um it ended up
ruining their lives and so i would not
wish that on any of the descendants that
i have
next piece is kind of the concept of
legacy which is like why don't you want
to do something like the rockefellers
and have some big trust and it feeds
every all of your generations from here
on out i think there's these ideas that
we all strive for of imper impermanence
excuse me permanence because we want to
live on after we die but i think it's
just a human condition thing and it's
just not reality you know if you think
about like
the sumerians civilizations from 5 000
years ago there's no one that we even
know about we just know that they
existed and that's about it and we don't
know about the rich people and the poor
people we don't know who started schools
and who didn't we just know that they
existed and i think that that may be the
americans in you know 5 000 years from
now and so there's the biological
component of all right so when we die
uh our kids are going to marry people
and they're gonna have kids and those
kids are gonna marry people and then you
do that a hundred times and it's taking
a 50 and then raising it to the
hundredth power you know sorry a half
and then just doing it over and over and
over and over again right and so
basically the amount of our genetic pool
um if you want to look at it from a
biological perspective of what 10 or 100
generations from now is is basically
nothing right we're not really there
and then the other piece of it is like
will they know who we were or any of the
character traits that we had will be
passed on unlikely
and so
um for us uh it felt kind of like the
right thing because we also feel like
we've been given a lot and not just from
being born in america and all that kind
of stuff but um
from a from a broader context i've
shifted my perspective on
i think business success over time and
so like let me give you a visual example
if you were to look at shaquille o'neal
versus let's say a tiny asian lady right
you could see a huge amount of genetic
diversity just in that visualization
and i think the same visualization
appears mentally it's just not visual
and so think about that for perspective
so like it's like why is he so good at
basketball well it's like if you look at
him you'd be like well geez he's so
naturally inclined for that i'm not to
say that every person who has his
genetic makeup would be you know as good
as he was but they would have an
inclination to be pretty good right and
so i think that the same exists within
your mental capacity and your character
traits but predispositions for business
like i wonder what if we were to look
through that same visual lens what jeff
bezos would look like mentally or what
bill gates would look like mentally or
what warren buffett would look like
mentally and all of a sudden we might be
like well it makes sense because he's
seven eight you know what i mean of
course he's good at investing or of
course he's good at business or whatever
and so i think that my perspective on
this has shifted because if you had
asked me when i was younger
what made me you know successful or
whatever i'm using quotes here i'm not
saying we're the most successful people
in the world or anything or far from it
but i think that i would have said hard
work sacrifice and all of that stuff but
i think as i've gotten more perspective
i think that we're just naturally good
at it you know and i think that
obviously work and sacrifice and those
things hone the skill just like
shaquille o'neal still has to go to
practice but i think some people get
disproportionate returns on their time
and effort and so to give back after we
are dead is not really asking that much
beyond that um it also gave me another
huge conclusion about my own life which
is if i'm going to be donating all of
this stuff when i die anyways
then it makes more sense for me to start
giving away while i am alive
and i think that you know the first
level of giving is obviously you can
give money and layla and i have probably
donated about a million dollars to the
last few years to various charities that
we believe in but
i think what has what is more valuable
is the skills um and the experiences and
the the traits and the lessons
that we have gathered along our journey
that i think is more valuable and so
the reasoning behind acquisition.com
which for those who don't know us is our
portfolio holding company right now it
holds uh up seven companies are
in entirety and then also percentages of
and um that does about 85 million a year
which just so you're curious which is
why i have nothing to sell you the point
behind you know this channel is to to
hopefully transfer those lessons while
we are alive to other people um because
if we're going to give it all when we
would die
why not start now at least that's the
that's the thought process behind him
and so that's why um for those of you
ask questions like that's why we are
writing the books that's why i'm making
the courses that's why i'm doing all
that stuff and we're giving them away
for free what's interesting is that i
think that there's a shift that occurs
and i'm just i guess noting this because
my first businesses were created out of
scarcity and so what i mean by that is
they were created out of an insecurity
they were created out of a deficiency
they were created out of a deficit a
need for something right one of my
favorite quotes from naval ravicon is
desire is a contract we make with
ourselves to be unhappy until we get
what we want and i and i candidly
us building those businesses was not
like a happy experience for me it was
very like grindy
dark rage filled like just outwork out
sacrifice type thing and what's
interesting is when i look at the people
who make a lot more money than me now
they don't kind of act that way and i
think it's because the motivation has to
shift because if you are this at least
for me
it's like if i'm only trying to satisfy
my own personal needs at 10 million or
20 million or 30 million whatever it is
whatever your number is you know when
you cross it maybe it's a million
whatever it is when you when you cross
that number in the bank all of a sudden
you'll feel the the energy or the drive
towards that satisfying that goal will
diminish because you somewhat do right
and so i think at that point there are
two directions that you can kind of go
in one direction is to make money the
ultimate scorecard um which i'll give
you an analogy of why i think that's
silly in a second and the other is that
you can change the driver all right and
so for the first one the reason that
i've never really been a big you know
i've never espoused that or never been a
big believer in that one is that i see
the entrepreneurial journey as a casino
and so bear with me for a second so
imagine every one of us is given a token
right as we you know come of age
whatever that age is maybe it's 12 maybe
it's 14 whatever it ages that you decide
that you want to get in the game right
and so we get a token and we go into the
casino and we get a seat at the table
and we continue to play we continue to
play and we have the other players right
and what's interesting is that
everyone's playing for the chips that
are on the table the difference is that
you might amass this big amount of chips
right
but the thing is is that we don't get to
cash out we literally just have to leave
the table and then someone else takes
our seat and all of our chips get pushed
back into the middle of the table for
other people to play with again and the
other people you could say is your
family the other people you could say is
your competitors the other people you
can see is just the marketplace your
community as a whole but either way we
don't get to leave the casino alive and
we don't get to leave with our chips
and so having that perspective for me
just really reinforces that it's just a
game because we don't get to keep any of
it and so once you're satisfied like
once you can eat steak dinners every
single night and it doesn't change
anything and once you can buy private
jets and once you can do all that stuff
like nothing changes like
more money changes literally nothing
because money can only solve money
problems and that was one of the lessons
that i've learned as we've you know
gained more of it is that money only
solves many problems and once you've run
out of money problems for money to solve
there's really not a lot of utility for
it that's why for me the the money
scoreboard concept has never really
resonated
me dying
a billionaire
so what
you know what i mean like i'm just going
to take this big lump of money and then
this is going to get handed to somebody
else
and so that is also why i i don't think
um we want to give it to somebody else
because you know an individual person uh
because i i think it would ruin them and
one of my favorite cards in magic the
gathering which is a game i played all
the time when i was a kid it was burning
wish and the the flavor text on that
card was uh she wished for a weapon but
not for the skill to wield it
and that's very much how layla and i
both see money is that it's just this
raw power and the more that you get
uh the more skill you must have in order
to wield it effectively and so i think
that that is why we don't we wouldn't
want to quote ruin our descendants um in
that way or ruin anyone in that way
because i think it's too much for one
person to have and so that is why we're
pushing it towards causes
rather than individuals because i also
think that when you give it to
individuals you rob them of the
opportunity to earn for themselves and
you rob them of the opportunity to
to to achieve in that way because i can
tell you i remember when i was a kid and
i thought about this really deeply when
i was uh in college
i thought to myself if i won the
powerball right because i bought a
ticket because it got like all you know
all the guys that i knew all got one
ticket because it was like a billion
dollars or something at one point for
the powerball
and it's more just for the conversation
that that that comes as a result of that
that we bought it it's not because i
thought there was like a chance or
anything
but what was interesting is that i
realized that during the drawing i
actually had this feeling of dread
because i really didn't want to win
because i realized that if i won then it
would kind of make everything that i was
wanting to do meaningless which was
really weird for me to think about i was
like if i just got a billion dollars
then it would mean that i never even got
to play the game or get the credit for
earning whatever i would end up having
because i wanted to have and this is
probably my ego or my insecurities i
wanted to have
people give me status for having earned
this
right but i think again as i've gotten
older my my thinking around that has
changed because like
there are so many things that i've been
fortunate with you know what i was born
with genetically you know what i mean i
think that i have decent reasoning
powers and i don't know how much of that
is
is learnable you know what i mean um
i think you know i was born in the
united states i was born a white male um
i was born to um you know a doctor uh as
a as a parent and so like there's lots
of things that i have that already gave
me
a leg up and so
anyways just to to bring this home for
you the reason that we have
acquisition.com and the reason that we
are pushing far more towards giving away
everything that we have is while we are
alive
and the most viable assets we have which
is the value that we can provide in
terms of the lessons and skills
is because
i just have no more marginal utility for
money now that being said
it would be
it would behoove me to kind of follow in
uncle warren's footsteps which is i
think that i will be a better allocator
and multiplier of capital so that when i
when we die we will be able to pass on
and make a larger impact um on you know
whoever you know whatever causes we
donate our stuff to
then if i were to donate it now
and we do donate stuff now because you
know i think about this where it's like
i've given away two million dollars in
the last two years and i think about two
million dollars in 40 years and how if i
you know allocated it well it would
probably be like
100 million dollars right and i'm giving
away all that money now
but i think there's always the trade-off
between consumption and investment that
you know kind of all entrepreneurs make
and the consumption investment
trade-off happens kind of for everything
it's like investing in your relationship
versus consuming a relationship
investing in the business versus
consuming the benefits of the money um
and that kind of happens with everything
right
and so that is kind of the the thought
process and the thinking behind the
books and the courses and all that stuff
behind acquisition.com for those of you
asked um the big impetus behind this was
uh you know donating what will you know
just our current estate is probably
valued between 60 and 80 million
depending on who's valuing the equity
slices we have in the businesses we own
i know that if i were to do nothing and
just wait you know 40 or 50 years
hopefully i lived that long it would be
a very big number right even at 10 it'll
be over a billion dollars at that point
and that's if we earn no more money
between now and then and so i think that
it changes the game and i'll leave you
this with this one quote from naval rava
cop that i think is really valuable you
said retirement is when you stop
sacrificing today for a hypothetical
tomorrow and i think that what that will
gave me
was the permission to stop doing that
because if i know that i'm not going to
be
i'm not going to be taking anything that
i'm making now with me anyways and i'm
going to be giving it a while all the
way to begin with it pretty much
eliminates the
desire to trade
time for money in any meaningful way
besides things that that i you know
enjoy and think that i can provide value
with and so for the many of you that
reach out um i want to also say a couple
things real quick one um we don't sell
time so i get probably like 100 dams a
day asking if we do one-on-one
consulting we do not we take on
companies that are
i say three to ten million but closer to
like the
five to ten million plus mark just fyi
unless you have something that's really
interesting um and so we you know we
invest and we take positions in those
companies and help them grow
for contacts at the time of this video
the smallest business that we have in
the portfolio is eight million a year um
so just like i said for context it says
three to ten but we're really skewing
towards the larger side of that and that
is why um i don't consult for dollars
that's also why we're not selling
courses we're not selling masterminds
we're not selling coaching and if you
see comments
in the thread that are replies from fake
alex ramoses right now we have we're
getting like targeted um and it's
probably because i think there's a lot
of goodwill on the channel because we
don't sell anything i will never ask you
for a whatsapp
all right so like please like do not
respond to any of the comments that have
a picture of me and like some weird
decimals afterwards to make it look like
it's
me i will never ask you for whatsapp i
will never text you for money all right
so please please please please do not
respond to those people do not feed uh
feed that um but anyways love you all um
hope you're amazing uh this felt like
the right time to make this video in the
parking lot before i go to the gym
and keep being awesome and uh if you
enjoyed this video click subscribe for a
lot more tactical stuff that we do about
growing businesses um and growing wealth
the point of this channel is there's a
lot of people who are broken i don't
want you to be one of them so without
further ado oxmoozy nothing to sell you
hit subscribe see you next vic